[Applaudissements]
la ressemblance est vraiment frappante
ce très bon imitateur est encore plus
convaincant grâce à un hyper trucage le
fameux type facebook bing com backstory
en superposant savoie il le visage de
celui qui limite
l'illusion est presque parfaite pour
faire rire mais le procédé est par
contre utiliser avec des objectifs
beaucoup moins louables notamment à des
fins politiques par exemple pendant la
campagne électorale
de plus en plus fréquente depuis deux
ans cette technologie se répand par le
biais des médias sociaux surtout
facebook
d'ailleurs le grand manitou de facebook
mark zuckerberg est devenu lui même une
cible d'hyper trucage en lui faisant
dire qu'ils contrôlent le monde
wang à quelqu'un qui regarde ça sur son
téléphone
oui mohamed dahmane et chercheurs
spécialisés en hyper trucage la
recherche pour les combattre avance mais
c'est loin d'être gagné
les gens qui font ça auront pris de l
avance par rapport aux méthodes pour les
détecter
c'est pour ça que maintenant je crois
qu'on est dans l'air de lier à contenir
s'apprendre l'intelligence artificielle
pour briser ce cas les gens font
développer des digues ferry on n'a pas
vu encore quelque chose qui a eu un
impact majeur il ya eu quelques
tentatives ici et là de désinformer avec
le deep est qu on n en est pas rendu là
mais facebook qui promet maintenant de
filtrer et d'interdire ce genre de
vidéos néfastes prend la menace très au
sérieux et s'associe à microsoft pour
demander l'aide de chercheurs en lançant
un grand concours avec à la clé une
bourse de 1 million de dollars
c'est un concours pour détecter ce qui a
été créé comme hyper trucage mais
comment filtrer les publications qui
peuvent circuler sur 2 milliard de
comptes facebook
il faut réagir avec les gens c'est pour
ça qu'elle devait combattre le mal par
le mal
à côté des divx des hyper que cage
contre les politiciens il y a maintenant
les charlots fakes vidéo moins
sophistiqué où on change par exemple la
vitesse ou l'ordre des mots pour
déformer la réalité grâce à ben c'est
vraiment un gars après plus convaincant
et ça ce n'est pas ça fait partie de la
nouvelle politique de facebook non
difficile à détecter ou de séparer le
faux du vrai ces vidéos trompeuses ne
sont pas près de disparaître et de plus
d'informations que déjà on est encore
long est à la remorque puis la vie c'est
aussi ça les aléas du progrès
technologique ici frédéric arnould radio
canada montréal